Germany has confirmed that when the Iran fiasco
was going down, Donald Trump threatened Europe
with an absolutely bonkers 25% tariff on European
cars. And the goal of this was to force Europe
to start proceedings against Iran for violating
the nuclear deal, which of course they only
decided to do after Donald Trump already had
pulled the United States from that deal without
Iran having violated it in any way. And this
really is going to require sort of a multilevel
analysis to unwind every absolutely ridiculous
and embarrassing aspect of this. So at first,
this was merely an allegation by the supposedly
fake news, Amazon, Jeff Bezos, Washington
post. And it just so happens that it's been
confirmed as really good reporting. The claim
in the Washington post was that Donald Trump
secretly warned France and Germany and the
United Kingdom, that the United States would
impose a 25% tariff on European cars if those
countries, if Europe didn't trigger the dispute
settlement process contained in the Iran nuclear
agreement, the German defense minister, uh,
Anna gret cramp, Karen Bauer said in London
that quote, the, this expression or threat
as you will, does exist.
It was indeed a threat that Donald Trump made.
Trumpists are pretending that everything's
fine and they're actually defending Donald
Trump's saying it worked because Europe reportedly
is now triggering the dispute mechanism contained
in that deal, except that every European country
is saying that they had already made that
decision before Donald Trump issued this threat
and it had nothing to do with Donald Trump's
threat whatsoever. So there's a few stories
here and I want to take time to go through
each of them. First of all, it is Donald Trump
who ruined the Iran nuclear deal. Iran is
now admitting they're enriching uranium beyond
the limits of the 2015 deal. And why wouldn't
they? It's the correct game theory move. If
you game this out, Trump bales on the deal
starting to enrich uranium, gives them more
negotiation leverage in the future, and again,
it's Donald Trump who bailed on the deal.
Anyway, Donald Trump then assassinating the
Uranian Koons leader, Kaseem Solemani cemented
Iran.
His decision to scale up nuclear development
number two, Trump is wildly and brazenly threatening
our allies with leverage that he actually
doesn't have here. That's what's really important
to understand. He doesn't have the leverage
as he is increasingly the laughingstock geopolitically
and of European us foreign policy and the
number three, and this is really important,
why would anyone get into any agreement with
the United States in good faith? When Donald
Trump sometimes backs out of deals, even when
the other country has stuck to its part has
done its its part to stay in the deal, to
stay in compliance with the deal and otherwise
we'll randomly threatened tariffs for unrelated
requests. If you're another country and the
U S says, let's do a deal, let's do a trade
deal, let's do a nuclear deal. That's let's
do a joint defense deal, whatever. But then
the next president comes into the United States.
Oval office says, you know, I didn't like
what that last person did and cancels the
deal. Why do you take deal seriously? Why
do you even get into deals in the first place
when you have all sorts of deals with the
United States and then the United States randomly
threatens you with a 25% tariff because they
want you to persecute another country. Why
even bother? Why would you see the United
States as a credible participant in deals
you wouldn't and the United States increasingly
is not seen as credible. This is how little
kids work and even little kids. There's actually
been interesting studies done where little
kids seem to have a very, they have a sense
of fairness that I don't want to say is innate,
but very early on in childhood, they exhibit
a sense of understanding of what fairness
means. They seem to exhibit more of that sense
than Donald Trump seems to exhibit and then
nevermind that because once again, Donald
Trump is threatening to punish Europe with
tariffs whose cost would not be born by Europe.
The cost would be born here in the United
States. Notice by the way, that for Donald
Trump, tariffs are Trump's hammer and so everything
looks like a nail. It's the only tool. Trump
has to use an analogy, someone told Donald
Trump about tariffs early on in his campaign.
Remember when he was running on, I understand
trade only I can fix it and tariffs are the
only tool that Donald Trump has and he threatens
to use that tool everywhere. Like a hammer.
A would be used, everything looking like a
nail when that's the only tool that you have,
whether it's with China for economic reasons,
whether it's with Europe here for foreign
policy reasons, I guess tariffs and maybe
the occasional bomb or assassination better
said are the tools that Donald Trump has.
It's all backwards. It's a completely farcical
universe that we're living in. Trump virus
violates the Iran nuclear deal sanctions.
Iran threatens Europe to get them to do more
to Iran. Europe wants no part of the bigger
picture, even though on the mechanism they
had already decided to trigger that, and we
once again are the laughing stock with the
leaders of other countries talking among themselves
about did you see this crazy thing that Donald
Trump did? As this is business as usual now
in the United States, it's an embarrassing
moment to be led by a the person that is in
the oval office. Now hopefully we can get
back to a more sort of rational and thoughtful
approach to these issues after Donald Trump
has gone. But removing Donald Trump is merely
step one in this process. And you know, the
early in Trump's presidency, I would say a
lot of the things that he's doing can be very
quickly undone. A lot of these symbolic executive
orders can be immediately canceled by the
next president.
Some of the policy stuff can be pretty quickly
undone by the next president. We are now in
the realm of this stuff will take a long time
to fix. Removing Trump is only one part of
it. We're talking of course of the relationships
with other countries that Donald Trump has
ruined and the credibility that's been lost
behind the scenes. We might think, well, you
just change the president and all that stuff
gets fixed. No, because there's a trickle
down effect from Trump to the diplomatic relationships
where a lot of the foreign policy has actually
done a lot of the foreign pop. By the time
Trump talks to another world leader, a lot
of the negotiation and the foreign policy
work has been done by the diplomats, the diplomats
from the state department and the diplomats
from other countries. The relationships that
Donald Trump has ruining trickle down and
affect diplomatic relations at many levels,
and it's going to take a very long time for
that to be undone and fixed even when Donald
Trump has gone.
I won't go into this again because we've talked
about it before, but then you've got judges
in the judiciary. It continues. I mean, even
now, while we are looking at the impeachment
Senate trial, a Donald Trump looking at making
bribery legal, I'll talk about that later
on in the show. Donald Trump calling his generals,
dopes and babies. I'll talk about that later.
We're, we're talking about all of these big
embarrassments meanwhile, and we're continuing
to cover it. The judges continue to be, to
be just swept in often to lifetime positions,
certainly to effect a American jurisprudence
for decades to come. And that is not going,
that's not even an issue of we've got to get
Trump out to undo it. It's, we've got to get
Trump out and then we need to wait a long
time for these folks to retire or die. Uh,
and then we are going to have another shot
at filling a lot of these judge judgeships.
So it's a disaster. We are covering it. We'll
continue to cover it. But importantly, step
one is an important one, removing Donald Trump
from office, but it is only step one is what
I want to convey to you today.